Hey guys!
Kumi here wants to say something for all of us.
You still don't believe me?
We're actually live you bitch!
You can't pull the same shit on me three times!
We're actually live!
I tried to pretend to be going live two times before.
And she didn't believe me.
And now that we're actually live...
Please!
Holy shit.
I fucking muted you instantly.
Hey you told me to beg.
You told me to beg.
Bro!
That's a little bit too much.
I told you to beg.
You told me to turn your sound guy.
Oh my god.
That was... Sorry.
I did not realize I had to turn that way down.
You told me to beg.
And I said I was going to put my begging pants on.
And you were like, okay.
I'm like, okay.
Tell your sound guy.
And you're like, why?
I told you!
Oh my god.
I'm so sorry everybody.
I did not realize.
How loud that loud was going to be.
And it was... It was loud.
This guy really...
Goomy really wants to be mod.
So I was like, just beg for it.
I was like, but not right now though.
Do it while we're streaming.
Do it for the whole world to see.
I am so sorry for everybody that went down there.
Hey sound dude.
What's up?
Alright guys.
Today is the day.
I can finally finalize this divorce.
And leave my bitch of a wife.
I get to leave my stupid asshole of a husband.
There's completely nothing in this house.
Wow.
I don't need your money.
You made me to be a trophy husband.
I...
Well you sure ain't a trophy.
I'll tell you that much.
Wow.
I know for sure that I'm a catch.
I'm a fucking catch.
Your mama?
You did.
You did when you married me.
Why would you marry a fucking farmer?
As an engineer.
Go into the plant.
Sometimes people lie.
Oh for like 10 plus years?
Like that child is like at least 10.
Go in.
I don't wanna.
Okay and we... this fucking stream will never end.
Hahaha.
This feels so nasty.
I'm so tired.
Okay.
Good.
Sorry I...
My... my hand slipped.
We did it.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
Wow you're so smart.
How did you know we had to do that?
You say something?
You have to do this thing over there.
You say something freak boy.
This is so not fair.
Why do you get to be DPS?
I'm like the support.
I'm the husband.
Oh that's better.
Why do you get to be DPS?
Hey ah.
No.
Wait what does that even do?
What does the water do?
Gumi.
Please.
Please for the love.
Oh you have to water the plants.
Go water the plants.
What plants?
In the fucking planter.
Where do you think...
I ALWAYS WATER THEM.
You just jump right into the pot.
Be one with your garden.
Yeah see you didn't fucking water them before.
They've been watered.
Wait how do I?
You're looking me go.
Yay.
Sorry.
Is that you?
I have to do all the work here.
Don't be.
Wait what?
You have to do this.
What the?
What?
Help me over.
Oh there it is.
Here I did it.
You're fucking welcome.
Look at me go.
Stay hydrated.
Even if you're getting in the forest.
Remember to stay hydrated.
Don't make me put on my begging pants again.
Down guy.
It's terrible.
That is what happens when you abandon your passion.
It gets infected.
Infected?
What?
Purple stuff is everywhere.
And it will keep spreading unless you stop.
I didn't get infected.
So Cody, will you nurture your passion?
Or will you start a new life?
What the fuck infected my garden?
No.
May, let's take this purple stuff out.
What the fuck?
Let's do it.
Why do I have to deal with it?
Because you're the wife.
Also give me.
I don't want that light.
Get this way.
Give me a sec.
I just need to make sure the sound is okay after I fucking had the swab.
Alright, here we go.
We're good.
Guys, I'm so quiet.
Guys.
No, no, no, no.
Don't believe her lies.
Do not believe her lies.
She's gonna go so loud later.
Don't believe her lies.
Oh, I got the DPS.
Look at that.
You wish you could do that.
Oh, it's we guys going for zombies.
She's lying.
She's the one that tempted me to marry her with that voice.
And then look at her now.
Look at her now.
They all change.
Can you like help me kill these guys?
What do you think I'm doing?
Oh, okay.
Good job.
What the fuck?
Well, that'll teach him to stay away from my guards.
Don't believe her lies.
Don't believe it.
It's a honey pie.
Don't believe her.
She's gonna take all your money like she took mine.
I didn't sign the freedom.
I'm the one that make money, doggy.
Wow, you're so pretty, Cody.
Broly's?
What the fuck?
I think I can help you across.
How do I?
Oh, I give you like a platform.
Is it here?
Come over here.
There you go.
Oh, I can't.
What are you doing?
And then...
There you go.
I don't think this is where we go.
No, I think this is as far as I can stretch!
You think it's that way?
I think I went the wrong way.
I don't know how I went the wrong way.
Guys, there is a possibility that I went the wrong way.
I don't know how.
Wow, but I think...
You're making these leaves so far!
What do you mean?
They're like perfectly... oh, how do I fucking get to you?
That's the furthest I can get to.
Oh, I can...
Hey, you know the piss flower?
The what flower?
The piss flower.
No, I do not.
No, no, gozo.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, I'm so thirsty.
Oh, you have to...
Oh, you're like watered... you got a watered pad!
It's the only thing!
I could fucking die!
Okay, now you have to go through the window.
Okay.
Now I go through the window.
Look at me go.
Here I am.
Now you have to die.
You have to die.
You have to die and go through the window.
No, I don't have to die!
Look!
No, no, no!
You make a leave there?
I can't get there!
What do you mean?
You go through the window.
I can't.
You go straight through the window.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
And then what?
Huh?
Make a leave!
Oh...
I forgot I could do that.
Oh my god, you're so smart.
This is why we got married in the first place.
You just... you knew the answers that I don't.
Okay, water this plant.
Yeah!
Where do I go?
Oh, I need to reconnect the fish.
You gotta reconnect the what?
The fish.
The fish?
What the fuck is the fish?
We just have to chop it all up, right?
Well, I hope it's that simple.
Okay.
I'm growing the leaves.
There you go.
Is that much better, my queen?
Is that a better...
Here, leaf grow for you, queen.
So demanding.
Hi guys, I'm...
Volume check.
Fuck off.
What's this?
Okay, here we go.
How do I do this again?
I don't remember.
I'll pull it.
Pull it.
Pull.
And then...
Open up!
Whoa!
Oh my god!
In front of me?!
You're gonna do that in front of me?!
I knew it.
Dude, you want me to let him fucking die?!
Wait, am I a cuck?
What the fuck?
Did you see that?
Yes, what was it?
What the fuck is that?
It's a ball or something.
Oh, that's not a ball!
Oh, that is not a... yeah.
Time to wax some weeds, Cody!
Oh, wait, how do I fucking contribute?
Oh!
Oh, oh, like this?
I'm holding on!
Hold it down!
Water it!
Oh, okay, never mind.
I guess you have to beat him up.
Do something!
I can't attack!
I'm gonna attack!
There's
creeps on me!
What can I do?!
I literally can't do anything!
Oh, I can attack.
By the way, I can also attack.
If you also wanna know.
I'm back.
I held it!
I held it with my fucking life!
Mine grows up.
Oh!
Oh, okay, that's on you.
I held it?
Oh, okay.
Just try to fucking...
Just dodge!
Why can't you just dodge?
There you go.
Look, I held him.
I'm holding him by the neck.
I'm watching all happen in front of me.
See that?
See, look at that.
I dodged.
It's just that easy.
Just move to the left and the right.
Okay, let me know when you're in melee range.
Damn, we...
We did it!
We whipped them into shape, didn't we?
Where do we go now?
Oh, okay.
Good one.
Bro, I don't know how to tend a garden apparently.
Yeah, what the fuck have you been doing at home?
This garden fucking sucks.
I don't know.
Raising our daughter because somebody else wouldn't?
She's at school!
She's literally ten years old!
She's literally...
At home?
At home right now!
It's the weekend!
Oh, now you fucking realize what day it is.
Wow.
I can't believe it.
You don't even care.
You come home late at night at like 9pm every fucking day.
Well, I have to raise our daughter.
I have to raise...
What?
Jeremy?
Who's Jeremy?
My boss.
Your boss?
No, I didn't.
Are you sure?
What about the first round?
I had to get a raise somehow.
Is this why you came home with a new car that night?
I thought you got a promotion!
Join?
I did get a promotion.
And a new car.
Well, that's...
What did you do for that promotion?
You know, I...
Well...
I just wanted to make sure that you didn't see that.
Oh, boy.
I need to run.
Sometimes... Okay, I feel like this game is giving the wrong message because it's teaching people that like...
You can fix a marriage even if they want to get a divorce.
Just let people get a divorce.
It should be normalized.
But like, if the marriage is already sort of like that bad...
I feel like if you're to the point where you're like this close to getting a divorce...
I don't think you should force yourself to make it work.
Oh, hey.
Here it is.
Jump further than me.
That's easy.
Alright, here we go.
How do I...
Weeeeee.
Dude, I used to be so fucking scared of this shit.
Wait, how do I let go?
What the fuck?
Oh, yes!
What the hell?
I was more patient than you for once in my life.
Wait, is that how momentum works?
Because I thought if you go all the way up...
Yeah, but I didn't go all the way like around.
So like I had more momentum going off because I got off.
Oh, my screen looked like it was all the way at the top.
Yeah, I had like... I didn't do it when I was like all the way up to the top.
I did like when it was just a little bit.
Also like someone super chatted.
Like that's what you get for marrying a woman with the name...
Ho at the end.
Holy...
Wait, what do you do?
Is that racially motivated?
What do you... what do you wanna... what do you wanna... no.
It's a Korean word.
Is that racially motivated?
Who's saying that?
Woooow.
Who's disrespecting it?
Anyway, I'm having a great time playing this game.
Anyway, this game has been really fun so far.
Woooow.
I'm having so much fun.
I'll turn this around anyway.
Woooow.
Water the fucking plants.
I'll turn this shit around.
Woooow.
Okay, I'm gonna jump on.
Hi guys.
Welcome to It Takes Two where we're having a great time.
This game is so fun.
Woooow.
Oh my god, playing with a good friend here.
Nothing controversial.
Oh, so we're friends.
Woooow.
Oh.
Okay.
What does this dragonfly do?
Is he just...
No.
He's just staring at us.
Oh, what the fuck?
Look at the graphics, man.
It's so good.
I know if you... Oh my god.
No wonder this game won game of the year, I think.
This game won... Did this game win game of the year?
What are you doing?
Yeah.
Wait, I need to drink water for this.
Okay, coming in.
Dude,
this reminds me of those carnival games.
Oh yeah, like the clown?
What the fuck is that?
That's a little spider.
What?
It's a... Wait, what the fuck?
That's not a... That's a sma... spider?
I need you to pull that shield.
That is not a... That can't be a spider.
We're wearing it down, man.
Keep it up.
That's a spider?
That's like a tree.
Okay, I've got...
Igumi.
Ignore him.
Think about the big guy.
Just run past him.
I can't.
It makes me auto-lock him.
Just fucking look past him.
There you go.
I did it.
Okay, it's fine.
I'll help you.
See, don't... Don't forget who helped you.
Easy.
Watch out, man.
More creatures.
Oh shit!
There you go.
I did it.
I pulled him.
Ignore the others.
They don't matter.
They're just babies.
Okay.
I'm holding on him.
Ignore the others.
What are you gonna do?
Kill you?
I like how...
I don't know.
Look at my health pool.
You're literally full HP.
No!
You're fine.
See?
Look, they're little babies.
It's like squishing snails.
Which I would never do.
I would never do.
I have never done whatsoever in my life.
I just tell other people to do it for me.
Okay, what the fuck?
I don't give a shit about it.
Okay, so do you never like ever be like...
I've been to a very humid place.
And then like, after it rains or it's raining and all the snails come out.
Yeah.
It's not... It's like...
They're everywhere.
You can't just like not...
They're just in your way.
You know?
Like you can just accidentally step on them.
It's not like I did it on purpose.
And then because like the whole walkway...
Because I have to go to school.
The whole walkway is like filled with snails.
Like I need somebody to...
Like make a path for me.
Oh, this is such a cute Spidey.
No, that somebody was my dad.
He would like make a pathway for me to walk through.
Because the whole pathway was filled with snails.
But then you can hear the audible crunch too.
No!
What about you?
We'll find another one.
Come on.
You need a win.
Oh, good for you.
Can you help me get to the other side?
Yay!
Wait, what do I do?
What do I do?
Why do you left?
What?
That's what the web was for!
Hello?
Are you gonna do anything?
I don't know how to use it.
What do you mean you don't know how to use it?
Okay, figure out how to use it before I do anything.
Okay, what are you doing?
What is that?
What are you doing?
I don't know!
Okay, I'm flying!
Oh, are you?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Do you know what to do now?
Why the fuck does he go hypers?
What the fuck?
Wait, wait.
What's going on?
Oh!
Nice.
Just keep filling it.
Alright, we're good.
I'm out.
I'm on the other side.
You can come back now.
Where do we go?
This way.
Why do he goes hypers?
No, hypers!
I found more.
Oh, it's another spider for me?
It's for me!
We get to ride our spiders together.
Oh my god!
They're a couple!
Get into force now before she takes everything.
Back that thing up.
Nice!
These spiders... I thought spiders don't have like husband and wives.
The female spider just eats the fucking male spider.
I thought like most insects just like eat the other one after they... after they bang.
Oh, it's even better!
Hey!
We do!
I like how somebody was like their siblings.
I mean, they're fucking bugs.
They don't care if they're...
I gotta hold on to my glasses!
Do they... do they care?
Don't like ants like...
Don't... wait, how did you do that?
How did you do that?
Oh!
I forgot how.
Okay, I figured it out.
I forgot the controls all of a sudden.
Where are we going?
Oh.
Wait for me!
I've never had a pet spider.
I'm so fucking far!
Wait, where are you?
Oh my god, you're so ahead.
Hey, Spidey!
You doing alright down there?
Oh me please.
I'm so behind.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh me please.
I was a little slow.
Just for today.
I'll wait for you right here.
Oh, just because you have to.
You're forced to.
Hi, Furs!
Very strong spider.
How do I get off this?
Oh, I can do it while I'm on the spider.
Whoops.
Fill that up.
Glup, glup, glup.
I wish that were me.
Fill that up.
Glup, glup, glup.
What?
Fill that up.
I wish Rose was here to see this.
I don't think Rose would want to.
Yeah.
Let's just give her more trauma, you know?
That's what a kid would want.
More trauma.
Yay!
Where the fuck is the end for this?
Is there an end?
I don't think so.
I think we were supposed to go up top.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah, we were.
I'm surprised, like, do we even have any friends outside of just us two?
You asked this last time too.
I don't know.
Hahaha.
I'm just assuming, like, wouldn't somebody visit us and be like, hey guys.
What the fuck?
What kind of fucked up plants are you growing?
Look, I need somebody to give me attention.
You see that thing on the left?
Hey, I'm giving you context clues.
You see that thing?
What thing?
That thing?
Right there?
Oh!
Okay, I almost walked the wrong way.
Don't worry, I got this.
Boom!
I missed.
But don't worry, I didn't miss this time.
Mr. Salmon.
Give me a dream.
Bum bum bum.
May you remember, that I've ever seen.
This is our brain on spiders.
Wait, where do we... oh, this way.
Wait, what?
Yeah, I need you to do something.
You can wash this off.
Oh!
My spider disintegrated!
What?
What kind of fucking gunk is this?
My spider got fucking Thanos snapped.
It's pesticides.
Are these pesticides?
There's no way.
Why would I just spray it on a fucking tree?
Like...
Of all things.
Oh, the gamer... what the fuck is a gamer gunk?
Oh, you're stuck?
Oh, right.
Uh, let's see.
How do I save you?
How the fuck... oh, here.
Okay.
Please!
Okay, I got it.
I think you have to... you have to jump.
Right?
I can't jump.
Wait, then what do you do?
You jump on this?
You jump on that?
Yeah.
And then you...
There we go.
Oh, I'm stuck.
And then you head over this way.
It's that easy.
Thank you for the ride again, spider.
Thank you, spider.
I'm gonna make sure we don't squish you when we're back to normal size, people.
This was me when I was like nine.
I used to be like... I don't know why, but I woke up in the middle of the night so thirsty for water.
You know how like...
Yeah?
Most Asian households have those kettles full of water?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I like used four... three to four cups.
Oh, that's the mama.
Oh my god.
So they weren't boyfriend girlfriend.
Didn't your chat tell you that?
Yeah, but like, do you really believe 100% what chat tells you?
If they played the game before, I would hope so.
Oh, I told you!
See, they have no fucking husband.
The spider killed the husband.
Meow.
I told you!
I didn't get to foreshadowing about what's about to happen.
Well, technically, I'm like the house husband, so wouldn't it be the other...
No.
That's not fair.
What the fuck?
I do so much around...
Who's gonna fucking do your laundry?
You don't know how to do your laundry.
What the fuck?
Whatever they are, we need to take them out.
Okay.
Here comes...
I got it.
How did you die?
What the fuck?
You, you like pulled it down right on top my head!
Whoopsie.
Me?
How was I supposed to know that?
Ahh!
Sorry, I fell.
Okay.
Alright, I pulled him down, I pulled him down.
I pulled him down!
That works?
What, I accidentally pulled...
Okay.
There, I pulled him down!
I pulled him down!
Hurry up!
I'm gonna take this!
Okay, we're gonna get rid of all these real fast.
Alright, your turn.
I pulled him down.
Pulling him down again.
I'm slapping him with my fucking head whip.
There you go.
Yay!
It was that easy.
Oh man, these guys can't... Oh my god, who are these... why are they doing here?
I'm pretty sure like the book grew these too.
The plants are way out!
Hold them up, Koji!
Got it!
Ewwwww!
Oh god!
Bro!
You know what?
You're right for asking a divorce.
You're...
Maybe like a divorce was a good idea.
I have to reload?
I'm a plant!
What am I wrong?
I'm reloading!
It's part of my body!
Get away from me, Koji!
I don't wanna be pricked in the back!
It's literally part of my body!
Oh my god, please.
Fucking spray faster.
Are we done?
Go go go go go go go!
Eh, there's a cutscene, man!
What do you mean?
I couldn't go.
I had to watch the plants grow!
Look, my life is clear.
Me first.
What the fuck?
Where do you go from... Oh, here!
Here.
We have to beat this shit up.
Yeah, beat that plant up.
God.
Eww!
What?
Woah!
Yeah, I was gonna say, is this my garden?
Yeah!
What am I doing in this garden?
Anyways, um, I used like three to four cups.
And then I was just so thirsty that I drank straight from the kettle.
Wait, wouldn't it... wouldn't that be like extra hot?
Or like, did you guys keep it in?
No no no, we have a cold one and a hot one.
Oh!
So you... I mean, less waste of...
Because my grandma...
You don't have to do... Yeah, you don't have to do more dishwashing.
Is that better?
Yeah, my grandma used to boil water in the morning and put it in a cold pot.
Yeah, that's smart.
Yeah, why would that be gross if you're all sharing in the family?
Eww!
Oh, that's a... that's a corpse!
No, it's a skin, you know like bug shed?
I think it's dead, Cody.
Oh no, it's dead.
Okay.
It's a corpse.
Shells!
They get so noisy!
No, it's like shedding.
It's shedding its skin.
It's a molt.
But yeah, um... I got pneumonia.
Oh, no!
You got pneumonia?
Who gave you pneumonia?
I got rid of them.
Clearly.
Or something like that.
I didn't... I drink... I was chugging water too much and I don't know why I was so thirsty but I got sick.
If we wait...
Wait!
I didn't like... water...
Who the f...
Water went down the wrong hole or something.
I don't think that's how... There's no way you can get pneumonia from just drinking water.
I think I also just got pneumonia somehow.
There's no way.
Oh, this is like... Okay, but what's the worst shit can happen?
We wake him up.
Watch this.
What the f... is wrong with you?
What is wrong?
Did you... Did you watch it?
Yeah, but... But did you watch it though?
I need to know if you saw what I did.
Do you want me to show it to you again?
Yeah.
They're actually quite cute.
Oh my god.
Did you see those teeth and claws?
They are kind of cute.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Who did you wake up?
What did you f... Why did you do that?
I didn't do nothing.
You know you could've went up?
Why did you go down?
I didn't want to go to the same place as you.
There's up!
I feel like we're invading their privacy.
Agreed.
Let's get out of here ASAP.
Oh my god.
Down?
Isn't like down harder?
I don't know.
I'm already through.
Yeah, because of all the noise you were making, I had to f... wait until...
I didn't make noise.
Okay, yeah.
You didn't make any noise.
Yeah.
Oh hey, look at all these ants.
Oh my god, these ants are so small.
Why do you have so much like motor oil over here?
I've seen like 50 jugs already.
Motor oil?
Where's the motor oil?
Oh my god, what am I doing while this...
No, there's... that's a wood sealer.
No, to the left!
That's one bucket of motor oil.
I've seen more.
One bucket of motor oil is not that many.
I've literally seen more.
Look, you don't know... it's okay, Gumi.
I know you don't know much about cars, but...
Oh.
But that... am I f... weed now?
Wow, look at you.
You look so soft.
Oh, you go...
Where are you going?
Why are you not following me?
I am!
You're just going too fast!
You're the one who isn't a sneaky bush.
Here you go.
You ready?
Come on, I'm going... oh my god, I am going as slow as I possibly...
I'm crouching!
Why are you crouching?
Just fucking run!
It automatically makes me crouch!
That sounds like a skill issue right there.
What the fuck?
No one is forcing you to crouch.
Oh my god, I have to piss on it.
Keep moving and deal with it.
Aim carefully.
Yeah, deal with it.
Oh, stop, stop!
Oh shit, that's a big boy.
Stop!
I see you fucking jump up there because you don't trust me.
You don't fucking trust me.
I can't believe...
What the... that was you.
That was you.
I was like perfectly in a quiet area.
I thought you were going to move.
You're right.
I don't trust you.
See, you don't even trust your own husband.
You'll need me.
I'm just going to leave.
Look at these.
These are my new friends.
The moles.
Oh my god, do you see that?
See what?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
That's so creepy.
Holy shit.
Wait, grab onto that.
Here we go.
Land on me.
I can't believe you wouldn't trust me.
I don't know why.
Hey guys!
Okay, five, four, three, two, one.
Okay, I see you.
I'm switching it.
Hi everyone!
What?
And I did swap.
What do you mean?
I did swap.
Wait, that one.
Look at that one.
Oh my god, it's an albino.
That's an...
What the fuck?
Why would you move?
It's an albino.
What is it going to do?
Breathe on you?
Why are you so paranoid?
Why are there so many?
Because they like to bang.
Oh yeah, they like to bang.
They like to bang.
I'm sorry for this one guy that just likes to fucking do his shit.
They're rodents!
Have you heard about that?
Have you ever...
Do you know about this mouse?
That like...
There's a type of mouse species for the guy whose whole purpose is to just like fuck until it dies from a heart attack.
Wait, you never...
Okay, there's a...
I saw this on National Geographic.
They were talking about the...
They were talking about this rat species that would literally just bang until it gets a heart attack.
It dies.
It's educational.
No, that's not all mice.
Some mice have their strength and know when to stop.
There's this particular species...
I know, it's going to make us go down.
There's a particular species that doesn't know how to stop for the guys.
And they just do it until they get a heart attack.
I think...
I think we have to run.
Oh, shit.
It's Crash Bandicoot time.
It's educational.
I'm...
How did you die?
No, I can just let you do all of this.
Because I'm here to let you do everything.
Oh, no.
No, I actually have to play the game.
Ow.
See?
What?
Why do you die?
Why do you keep jumping?
No, it forces you to play.
I'm not even pressing anything and it forces you to play.
That's so fucked up.
I can't believe it.
It's not a choice.
It's okay.
Why is your way faster?
It's not fair.
Oh, don't worry.
We're gaming.
I'm ahead.
What have we ever done to these moles?
Why are these...
Why do you only want to kill us off?
I literally provide them food.
You didn't take care of your garden.
I literally provide them free food with my garden.
It's rotting!
Did you see it be rotting?
No, no, no.
That's not my fault.
It's the book's fault.
The book caused this.
Oh, man.
I thought he was going to get us.
Are you...
Oh.
Maybe he wants to say hi.
Oh, no.
It's not my fault.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
That poor mole!
No!
Haiyaa!
Of these moles!
Oh my god!
We're monsters!
Are we bad people?
Oh.
Oh!
It's okay.
He's still breathing.
That's not him.
Oh.
Good luck.
I believe in you.
Oh, look.
He got me!
See, look, everything is fine.
Oh my god, it's just like Little Nightmares.
Oh my god, the gnome.
What is up with me and gnomes?
Wait, there's a treasure!
Guys, we have to go back here when I'm bigger.
Oh my god.
I won't need your money anymore.
Wait, what?
Goodbye.
There's more?
Holy shit!
What kind of fucking family is this?
There has to be incest involved.
Stop fishing!
The toads!
Woah, what?
They can talk?
Taxi!
We're going to the greenhouse.
Nah, we don't go there.
Bad neighborhood, huh?
Nah, they have no culture.
Bad neighborhood.
The crap has destroyed everything.
Far as we go is the garden fountain.
How much?
Fis price a prontus.
We love they eat you.
Where the fuck did I found that?
God, that is disgusting.
Hey, hold it, big boy.
My back is killing me today.
Hey, you take the fat one.
That's my wife!
What?
Come on, you little gay boy!
Hey, you, come on!
Over here!
Come on!
Oh, sorry.
Namaste.
Oh my god, you made me look sad.
Woah!
Oh my gosh, where am I though?
Okay.
Look!
It's more motor oil down there!
No, I, what do you mean?
That's not, that's, that's called, uh...
That's like the wood thinner.
Look at that crap of crap everywhere!
It ruins the, uh, atmosphere!
You know what I'm saying?
Why are they like, New York?
But we're here to find the source and clean it up!
Well, one of them is French.
You have such a big gullet.
You have no taste.
You American people.
Oh my god!
Wait, isn't this frog American?
No, that one's French!
Yeah, but he's in America!
There's no way he was...
That doesn't make him American!
There's no way this tadpole was born in France!
There's no way!
They do not live long enough to travel from France to America.
Are you okay?
Frog?
I have a strong...
What are you?
I'm gonna try that downward frog one day.
Sorry, I had like a war flashback.
What happened?
Thanks for the ride!
I'm gonna go from here.
How you doing back there?
Good, thank you!
Oh my god, it's like Frogger!
Oh!
Don't get into the gunk!
You're gonna disintegrate.
I need you and your frog!
Oh, what?
Oh, I actually need you for this guy!
Okay, you go to the right.
And then I'll push a button.
Yeah, and then I'll push this button.
And then you go to that one.
See?
Teamwork!
And then you push that.
Look at that!
Frogs can work together.
Well done!
That was close!
Oh my god, look!
A little frog statue!
Oh!
I have a weird obsession with frogs apparently.
God, I'm perfect!
No wonder you married this man.
Did I have like a weird thing?
Yeah!
About frogs.
Why?
Because um...
Okay, you need to be here.
Sorry, I saw a platform and I instantly jumped.
We have to...
Oh, we have to get out.
By the way, don't open it while you're under the thing.
You have to find a way past it.
You have to go under that.
Oh!
Don't worry, you got this.
I believe in you.
Anyways, when I was younger, you know those Chinese supermarkets that like...
you just order like fresh fish or some shit?
Yeah.
Okay, do I get in the frog?
I do.
Yeah, yeah, keep doing that.
Okay, keep going with your story.
Hold on, let me get to the other one.
Um...
I went with my grandma.
And...
She ordered a frog and I watched it get skinned right before my eyes when I was like 8 years old.
Oh, wait, was it an Asian supermarket?
Yeah.
That's why I said...
But yeah, it like picked me up so much that she gets skinned.
Yeah, they get hardcore sometimes.
Nice.
Wait, how do I get you across?
How do I get you across though?
I'm already over.
But I don't know how to get you over.
Can you like...
How are you supposed to come over here?
Oh, I went backwards!
You have to do this.
I jumped the wrong way.
It's okay.
I don't know what to do now.
Gooby, why didn't you say anything?
I'm like...
I wasn't watching your screen.
I was looking at my screen.
Why weren't you waiting?
I timed it!
You... Okay, that's not me.
That's not me.
I had it perfectly... You went backwards in the first place!
I timed it perfectly, okay?
I timed it perfectly to your rhythm.
And then suddenly your rhythm stopped.
How was I supposed to know the rhythm will just disappear?
Huh?
I was like like right now!
Like right now!
I'm shooting it!
Wait, what?
Was I not supposed to jump that one?
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
See?
Look at this rhythm that you have established.
And then suddenly it's just gone?
Yeah, and then?
I'm just making sure.
And then look!
Look!
I have to wait an extra like five seconds!
You can get off now.
Oh!
That's it?
Okay.
I got you.
How did you get up here?
Nice job!
Thank you, frog!
Alright, here you go.
Go beat that shit up.
Look at Kata here.
Well, maybe they are French Canadian.
Wait, I actually need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back real quick.
Oh my god.
Don't say anything weird to my chat.
I'm gonna say anything weird.
Anyways, um...
Chad?
Um...
Can I tell you guys a story?
Oh!
Dude!
I love this story, but...
I was playing Truth or Dare with another kid back in elementary school.
Actually, it was a group of four.
I'm not gonna say their names, but there was...
a kid who...
um... they...
I don't know why they decided to tell us this, but we were like, Okay, Truth, what is the grossest thing you've done?
And then...
they were like, oh...
I would pee.
So, like...
I would... I...
We had mice in our house.
And they were like...
They would pee.
On their floor.
And leave crackers.
Because they were like, oh, the mice are thirsty!
And they're probably hungry.
And then we were like, dude, that is not normal.
That's not normal.
And they were like, oh yeah, my... my dad yelled at me for it.
I'm like, yeah!
I would think so!
Anyways, I told my about it.
And she's like, Gumi, I hope you never...
talk to that kid ever again.
Anyways...
That's a story that I love telling.
It's like pee pee for the mice.
Hmm, my rat's thirsty.
Let me pee on carpet.
Yeah...
Right, Doki?
Why aren't you talking?
Did you say to my chat?
What?
Did you say something weird to my chat?
No, the plot twist is that... Why are people in my chat being like, Doki, please never leave...
leave us alone with Gumi again?
What did you say to them?
I didn't say anything!
I told them a story from my past!
Bro, okay.
Okay, that explains everything.
Some of the shit that happened to you when you were younger...
I understand why you're like this.
That wasn't me!
Oh my god, no, there was another...
So, do you know what that same...
Shoot or Dare?
Hold on.
That same Shoot or Dare...
Oh, there's a game!
There's a game!
There's a snail race!
Get over here.
There's a Shoot or Dare?
Um...
We're playing Shoot or Dare and then...
You know how like kids back then were like, I see London, I see France, I can see your underpants?
Yes...
Um...
Basically... I don't need to rule enough for this.
We were like, we dare you to show your underpants and then the kids...
What?
Yeah!
Like as an embarrassment!
What does that even mean?
What do you mean?
Like, as a what?
Get away from me!
No.
Wait, which one's me?
Oh, that's me.
Okay, I lost track of who I am.
I don't know.
I think you're like... Show your underpants!
What?
And then... This kid not only... How old were you guys?
We're like eight!
And you thought that was okay?
No!
We thought it was embarrassing!
We're like...
Show your underpants!
Like, pants yourself!
Yeah!
Slimey later!
We'll credit you to your style!
And then... No!
This kid decided to like...
take off his pants and his underpants and pee on the like, playground floor in front of us.
And then we got a...
The dean... Like, a teacher saw it!
And then the dean got mad!
I mean, Ed!
Of course people would you... No!
Of course!
I know!
We didn't ask him to fucking pee on the floor!
He just did!
And then the teacher got mad!
Like, I mean...
Anybody would be mad!
Like, they'd be like... Oh my god!
What is going on?
Anyways...
And...
I'll never forgive this bitch!
The other kid who was playing with us?
She said it was my fault!
But I didn't dare him to do that!
Oh my god!
That could've been a fucking lawsuit!
Right there!
Get the fucking plants watered!
Red!
Blue!
Okay, I'm good.
I'm good.
Anyways...
Mom, pick me up!
That happened to me!
I'm scared!
That was the same truth or dare...
game.
Alright!
You made it!
The same what?
What did you tell them earlier?
Huh?
Kumi, stop cooking!
Turn off the stove!
Thank you for the super chat!
I'm not cooking anything!
I'm just telling childhood stories!
Before saying you're like the creepy uncle!
We're almost there!
Don't kill him!
That's what he said!
The creepy uncle!
No!
I'll never... I'll never leave you alone with the creepy uncle!
Don't worry!
I've learned my lesson!
You got some more purple gunk here!
I think I have to spray this and then like unearth something.
Oh, this?
Oh, here!
Water this plant!
Water the pink flowers!
I'm the cool aunt!
What the fuck am I doing?
Where are you?
It's really magical watching you make all that grow!
Oh, do I have to grow this?
This is where I love gardening!
Oh!
I have to make this pretty again!
Right?
Yeah!
It has to be!
Oh, there's a...
Oh yeah!
I had to make it beautiful!
Yeah!
Alright, I held him!
I'm not over there!
I held him?
Okay!
Alright!
We gotta hurry!
I held him!
That's the plant!
Ow!
Okay, I got it!
I got it!
Don't worry!
You did not get it!
I got it!
Do you not see me reviving?
I'm holding on him!
I can't break through!
Oh god!
I'm getting shot at!
I am 1 HP!
I'm holding!
He's literally 1 hit!
It's okay!
I need to get rid of the fliers first.
Okay!
Don't worry!
I got you!
Anyways, maybe that's why I'm not normal.
And that's how you do it!
Wait, how do we hold?
Oh, okay!
There you go!
Can I help out with this?
It looks like you are!
I'm the cool aunt!
Dude, I feel like I told you so much...
Well, not you.
But I feel like I told you chat so much about my childhood past few takes 2 streams.
Me talking to clay when I was younger.
Anyways...
Oh yeah, the clay story.
Yeah, when I was locked up.
Yeah, now we sort of know why you're like this.
No, my family was so tough on me What?
What did you do?
But like, why?
I got a C.
Oh, you got a C for your book report?
No.
They just decided to do that as a punishment.
Like, but why did you kill- was this the first book they found?
Yeah.
So how did you- so how was the book?
I didn't- well, I read the book.
I read it.
So like, how was the book though?
I didn't finish the assignment.
Wait, you didn't finish it?
And because I didn't finish it, I had to get locked in my room for a whole week.
Oh my god.
Also, we were supposed to go to the other side and water this area.
So how did you- Yeah.
So no one- so that's why you don't like reading?
No, I love reading.
Wait, then why don't you read?
I didn't finish to kill a mockingbird.
I did.
No, you said- I finished it like four times.
You just said you didn't.
I didn't finish writing it by hand, man.
Oh, then when I asked you how was the book, you were like, oh, I didn't finish it.
Oh, and then you were asking me how was like finished writing it.
No, I said how was the book?
You like it because- Yeah, it was pretty good.
I liked it.
Okay, but did you like it because of the punishment that you got Stockholm Syndrome for it?
No, I liked it before.
Or did you actually like it?
Actually, maybe it could have been Stockholm.
Yeah, I was gonna say it could have been Stockholm Syndrome because of- Because you wrote so much of it, you just had to like it at that point.
How the fuck do we fix this- fix this plan?
How do we fix this?
She had to read it to be able to argue her way out the gulag?
No.
I got the gulag!
Holy shit.
How the fuck do we- Um...
I had to plant more?
But I planted so much!
Oh, it was like this tiny patch!
That's so stupid.
It was like literally the tiniest fucking patch of- The little tiniest thing that I didn't fucking planted.
Don't worry, I'm helping.
The one spot.
Anyways, uh...
That's all the childhood stories I have for you today.
I think like the most exciting thing from my childhood was, um...
Was when like I was alone in my- I was- My parents left me home alone.
And then like I made like this makeshift fishing pole.
And like...
I sat in my- And there was like this drawer thing.
So I would like pretend I'd be fishing and stuff.
Um...
I would- I went to my parents' room.
I was like pretending I'm fishing.
And then my hook accidentally hooked into the drawer.
Like this giant drawer cabinet thing.
And then I p- Me being a little dumbass was like, Oh my god, I caught a big fish!
And then I like pulled it so hard that the entire drawer like fell down.
But like I was so lucky because like I freaked out and I like- Pull it!
Pull it!
I freaked out and I like dropped down.
And then the bed, like you know like the backboard, the frontboard thing.
Where are you?
Where- Why did you leave?
It made me touch the hose.
I don't know what.
But like the bed, like frontboard thing blocked the drawer cabinet from squishing me.
So I could have been dead.
I could have actually died.
And then what's fucked up was that...
Um...
My parents, like recently, they like found- Cause they- The furniture for our old furniture when I was little.
My childhood furniture and stuff.
Was uh...
Was being stored somewhere.
And then my parents recently got the furniture out.
And like now that drawer that almost squished me is in my bedroom.
Oh ho!
Hahahaha!
That's it.
We're down to the last!
And then when my mom, like when my parents like moved it into my bedroom.
They're like, remember this drawer?
Doki, do you remember this drawer?
That's the drawer that almost killed you!
And I was like, alright.
Hahahaha!
Ah, memories!
Ew.
What the fuck I'm seeing some guys.
Oh god.
Oh I see.
Oh ho.
Oh my god, it's boss battle time.
No, Joy!
Maybe we're too late!
Ew, it's breathing at us.
Be careful.
Oh my god.
She cute.
It's okay, we're here to help.
It's Cody!
I made you.
Do you remember me?
Hello beautiful flower.
I made you.
Oh.
She crazy, I like that.
Hahahaha!
Oh!
I can fix her.
Hahahaha!
What?
It was me!
You fucking bastard!
It was me!!!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, I need to be immersive here.
I need...
Hahahaha!
Wait, give me a sec!
There has to be like, some immersion here.
Let me know before you unpause.
Okay, I'm ready!
Are you ready?
No!
I'm ready.
Are you ready?
I'm ready though.
No, I'm not ready.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Okay, I'm ready.
Okay, okay.
I'm ready.
Alright, I'm ready for the immersion.
It's immersion time.
Oh my god, I'm stronger as a tomato too.
Look how strong I am.
I can't move!
You have to un-gunk it!
I'm literally washing right now!
Un-gunk it!
It's lore accurate.
Who would have thought?
I knew being a husband was the right idea.
I knew I was meant to be a husband.
There you go.
Okay, I'm literally washing it.
I think you need to...
I'm trying... No!
No!
My show is so short-lived.
It's okay.
That's all of them, eh?
Give me some water over there.
What do I do?
She has a name?
Yeah, you named her.
I named her?
New wife.
You're what?!
You jealous?
Are you jealous?
I am!
You jealous, aren't you, Gumi?
You wish you had this!
I actually am not.
I'm just surprised that's happening in front of my face.
You wish.
Now you regret what you can't have.
I think I'm chill, actually.
What are we doing here?
Where's this?
There's something growing out of her!
I see that!
Joy!
We've come to save you!
No!
Don't do it!
I can fix you, Joy!
Think of all the good things we did together!
Oh.
This is like Baby's first platformer.
It's like Cuphead!
Have you ever played Cuphead?
No.
Me either.
Oh, fuck!
Man, it's Baby's first platformer, alright!
It's Baby's first platformer!
I'm still alive!
Wait, wait, okay.
I made it.
I made it too.
Look at that.
I think this flower is better than Poison Ivy because she's more plant.
She doesn't need a Compensate by being half human.
She's full plant.
And that's why we love her.
What are you on about?
What?
You don't think she's hot?
Look at her!
That's my new wife you're talking to.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, is it time?
Oh, I'm a potato!
I'm a potato!
Really?
You really think now is the time for jokes?
You know what he thinks?
I'm washing it!
The freakiest ones are the ones with multiple eyes.
Like the potatoes with multiple eyes.
Have you seen that?
Yeah.
That shit is so freaky.
Where the fuck is the...
Where's the... Oh, there it is.
I'm on it.
I'm a... Just don't hurt my new wife!
She's too beautiful to die.
And a little... She's too crazy to die.
I like them a little crazy.
Alright, get in her!
Don't worry!
Watch this.
Are you watching?
I need to be sure that you're watching.
I'm busy.
Okay.
Get over here!
You have to go down my arm!
My beautiful sexy arm.
Oh my god, it's from my back.
Don't stick your fertilizer into crazy!
Oh my god.
You can't tell me what to do!
I'm gonna put all the fertilizer.
So she'll grow up big and strong.
Just like how the gardener likes it.
What's gonna happen?
I don't understand this.
Oh, what?
What is this?
What is she gonna do?
Oh...
Oh, okay.
It's just dodging again.
But this time we're in the air.
It's just...
It's just dodging with extra steps.
Easy.
Let's go.
We're so smart.
Oh, now there's less...
Oh, okay.
It's okay.
Okay, the plate to the right is gonna break.
Not yet.
This plate is definitely gonna break though.
What?!
I tied them perfectly!
Don't die!
I'm good now.
Whoa!
Here, sentry.
Wait, that...
Ah!
Don't die!
I didn't tie them perfectly!
Look, it is easy.
I'm just trying to make you look good.
Well, you've been doing that quite a bit.
I mean, you clearly meet the wind here.
Nice.
Don't worry.
Are you ready to watch again?
Oh, my God!
I'm a lemon!
It's a lime!
Look at me go!
Oh, my God!
It's making squeaky noises!
Here we go.
I'm doing it.
Where's the other one?
Oh, the other one's right here.
A lime is just a lemon that just wants to be special.
Okay.
Get over here.
She's got major flow of energy!
Okay, you have to kill that one guy.
Oh, my God!
I'm trying to wash the floor for you!
Watch the group!
This lemon is not doing so well!
There's one more here.
One more here.
Alright.
Oh, my God!
I'm cracking right now.
Alright, we're good.
Are you watching?
Hahaha!
Now turn around!
I need you to keep watching!
She spawns!
I can't!
Three times?
Damn, Cody!
Hahaha!
That's when you know it's true love.
Alright, I need you to hit my head.
And we're gonna get rid of it once and for all!
We're doing it!
Oh, they can't even touch you!
Yeah, that match is better not touch you.
Don't look away!
Hahaha!
I told you she's beautiful!
It really is!
Oh, my God!
Are you okay?
Are you okay, wife?
I am now!
Whoa!
Why can't you be nice like Joy?
Don't thank me!
I don't want you, man!
Go ahead, date a flower!
Hahaha!
I'm sorry!
No!
What the fuck am I sorry about?
I didn't understand how important it was for Cody!
Bro, are you the...
Hahaha!
That's good!
Oh, my God!
Look, we got an approval!
Cody gave up on being...
Oh!
Because I got caught!
Hahaha!
She caught me with...
my Joy!
Hahaha!
Yeah!
Idiot!
Don't worry, Joy.
I'll never give you up.
You're clearly better...
than this bitch.
Hahaha!
I'll never give you up, Joy.
I hope you're happy with Joy.
I am.
I'm so happy.
Let me look at her!
She's so pretty!
My God!
Imagine being this fucking kid and seeing these things happening!
Bro, she clearly...
She already has trauma.
Oh, my God!
It's a stupid clown thing!
And an octopus!
Oh, yeah!
I still can't believe a millennial...
bought a fucking jack-in-the-box.
I mean, to be fair...
she's already going through trauma.
So it's just one more thing...
for her therapist.
Hey, that's what my family said too.
Hahaha!
Hey!
Fuck it!
Make me the right to kill a mockingbird again!
Hey!
Fuck it!
Make me the right to kill a mockingbird again!
Hey!
Fuck it!
Make me the right to kill a mockingbird again!
Letter piece numero...
three!
And now...
how do you find...
your purpose in life?
Through...
passion!
Passion?
Again?
I already have Joy!
Now, it's time to find...
Yeah, who's your Joy?
Who's your Joy?
Everyone has a passion!
Who's your side piece?
I'm getting a phone call.
Hold on, I'm getting a phone call.
Jeremy?
You want me to stay...
stay up late at the office again?
Oh, we have overtime again?
Oh, God!
You want me to wear something nice...
for over...
Oh, don't worry, Jeremy.
Letter piece numero...
What the f...
What the fuck was that?
Mess!
Yeah, we really need to clean up our attic.
Hey!
You recognize this suitcase?
Huh?
What is that?
Oh, I don't like where this is going.
Uh-oh.
Is that Beep Boombox?
Daddy!
It's a record player!
Oh!
Welcome to the concert hall!
Mae!
It's time to sing!
Oh, no, no, I can't sing.
I haven't done it for years.
Come on, Mae!
It's the last letter piece unless you sing.
You just get up on that stage and you show them what you've got.
All you have to do is sing!
I have to fucking...
I have to fucking save my garden and save my joy.
We need that!
Oh, my God, my joy with singing!
I'm not gonna sing a single note.
Who are you singing with?
Is this gonna turn into a musical?
Oh!
What?
Will you turn that off, you stupid...
Come on!
Is this the musical episode?
Every show has one.
And they're always terrible.
She sure does, Cody.
And you will help her find her voice again!
Dabba!
Oh!
Now, go and buy some...
Oh, it's like that fucking singing game!
The...
Um...
What was it?
The clapping one?
Have you ever seen that singing game where you have to actually sing in the microphone to actually get stuff done?
Okay, let me swap back my skin suit.
I feel a little naked.
Let me change real quick.
I'm a little naked here.
Give me a sec.
Okay, I'm good.
One hand clapping?
Yeah!
One hand clapping!
That's what it reminds me of.
That's the actual title?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
It's like this...
It's like you actually sing in the mic and then it like fucking registers your voice and stuff.
What do I do with this fucking...
Oh!
It's like a little discus.
What are you supposed to do here?
Whoa!
Is that game over there?
Yeah, that's the game.
That's the game.
That's the waste track.
Hey Cody!
Over here!
Alright.
Complete three laps to win.
Don't leave me at the lost things!
Which way does it go though?
Oh, it's on the left.
Am I... What color am I?
Oh!
I'm green!
How do you do that?
What?
What are you doing to it?
I don't know!
I don't... How are you controlling it?
I'm not controlling it, man.
Oh, we can go to the next level.
Too fast!
Oh!
Look, instructions unclear.
I didn't know you could...
It didn't say.
It didn't tell me that you had to slow down.
I just assumed we go fast and we turn.
Okay, I figured it.
I'll be honest, I've just been tapping it.
Okay, I understand now.
Don't worry, I can catch up.
I can catch up right here.
Rematch!
No, no, no, no!
This time!
This time, now that I know the game.
Whoa!
Wait, how are you so faster than me?
No!
I'm done.
I know my limits.
Ooh, the backstage.
This is where I'm gonna meet Jeremy?
Yeah, he's my manager.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Why is it so scary?
Why abandoned dreams live here?
This is where your hopes and dreams die.
This symbol is like a shield.
I'm the symbol superhero.
Why didn't I get a shield?
You got the greatest weapon of all.
Yeah, your voice.
Oh!
See, I can still be romantic.
This is a powerful maid.
What's this?
Aim and throw.
Oh, I have to cut this myself.
Oh, what the fuck?
You can kill stuff with your voice.
Oh, who broke the fucking...
Someone broke the lever here.
We're not alone.
Oh, that's cool, actually.
Okay.
How do we do this?
Oh, yeah, it is like one hand clapping.
Ow!
What?
Does it get too hot?
Oh!
You have to keep singing because it gets hotter.
When it's like up, it cools down.
Yeah, see?
You have to keep singing!
Do I have to make you get all the way over there?
I think so.
Right?
Oh,
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, you have to keep singing for now.
Oh!
I think it... What?
Is there a pathway?
I feel like you have to keep singing until...
Because there's a thingy on my thingy too.
There's a thing?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Wait, I can jump and sing at the same time.
Oh, okay.
You know what?
Hahaha!
I thought it was one of those that I had to stand still for.
Yeah, but you can actually move when you're singing.
How did I miss?
It's okay.
What?
Oh, hey, you have to come back.
Hey, I missed the last jump.
Hey, hey, hey, wife.
We're still not finalizing our divorce yet.
Wife.
Hey, wife.
You can't go there without me, wife.
Okay, try dying now.
See if it gets you...
Hey, wife.
Oh, my God.
Look, I know you don't want me to meet Jeremy, but I let you meet my joy, so I think it's fair.
Huh?
I think it's fair that, you know, we meet each other's, you know, happiness.
Alright, nice.
I'm here now.
Don't worry, I can't miss this time.
I'm out.
I'm out!
Just keep singing!
I asked!
The bar was empty!
Okay.
Okay, alright.
You come back and, like, chill.
Okay, never mind.
I guess not.
What do you mean?
I come back and chill.
I guess not.
I came back?
Okay, alright.
Look, we can do this.
This cannot be the puzzle that we struggle the most.
What do you mean, we can do this?
This cannot be the puzzle that we are married, so our troubles are shared.
I've already signed the prenup.
I forgot to sign the prenup.
What?
Alright, here we go.
See, look at that.
We did it together.
It's not a skill, it's a group skill issue.
Damn.
Oh.
Yay!
Alright.
I guess I go up?
Oh, maybe I might cut this?
No?
Oh, I have to cut the thing over here.
Wait, no, I have to get you over here.
Wait, how did you get here?
How did you get here?
I didn't look.
There's a microphone right here.
Oh!
I did it.
You're welcome.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Your grandpa was sick as hell.
Oh my god.
Alright, we need to grab the last coin.
Alright.
Oh!
Here we go.
Alright.
Oooh!
Look at that funky beat.
Okay.
We have to go this way.
I love my grandpa!
I'm pretty sure if we sell this we can get a lot of money.
What the fuck?
I'm just saying.
If somehow...
If somehow I go broke.
I have to thank grandpa for this.
Wait, what do we...
I need this thing here.
What's this for?
Oh, I have to break this.
Wait, I'm breaking my grandpa's jukebox?
That's fucked up.
Keep going.
Keep shouting.
Keep destroying my hopes and dreams because it doesn't matter anymore.
This is my grandpa's jukebox.
What do you mean?
Oh, now you left in the attic because you just stopped caring.
Okay, now I have to push.
Jesus, what the fuck is that?
Oh...
Let's fire this baby up!
Let her rip, babe!
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have to bring this up.
I was like, why is this working?
Alright.
Put down.
Okay, here we go.
We're upping up the base.
Oh, shit.
You going?
Alright, I'm all the way up.
What the heck?
Where are we?
Why do you have all the way up?
Why do you have all this equipment?
I thought this was just a hobby.
Good work, both of you.
You've earned the speakers.
We've earned the speakers.
What?
What's the speaker for?
Keep on going.
You're still missing the mics and lines.
Woohoo!
Boots gonna be toasty.
What the hell?
You've been first, Cody.
I'll use your symbol for it.
Oh, I blocked the thing with my symbol.
Watch this.
BAAAAM!
My lady.
Oh, no thank you.
Chivory's dead.
Wait.
Here we go.
BAAAAM!
Wait, why can't I fucking get past this?
Oh, I have to go like that.
Still no thank you, fucking Chivory.
Chivory's dead.
Oh, look, look, look.
Over there.
What?
You have to do something over here.
I do?
No, look at this pad, because it matches colors with these.
Ohhhhh.
Wait, what?
Oh, you have to go B.
Yellow, yellow.
I think.
And then you take me straight up.
Wait, what?
D then?
Oh, it's D.
Oh, the B base!
Wait, how do we go up?
Oh, no!
B, B, B.
B.
Yellow?
Yellow, yellow, yellow.
Green.
Or A.
Not.
Orange, orange, orange.
Okay.
Keep going.
Orange.
Which way is this?
Ah!
Wrong way!
You gotta send it back.
Okay, I figured it out.
I'm not on it, I'm not on it!
Oh!
I thought I had to send it back.
Okay.
Orange, orange, orange.
Orange.
Okay.
Purple.
Orange.
Oh my god, I can't see.
Purple, purple, purple.
Purple.
Green.
Oh my god, we're so smart.
Purple.
Yeah!
We did it!
Look at this teamwork!
Oh, god.
We got it!
What do you mean, oh?
Oh god.
I was the one that had to dodge the fucking shields.
Bam!
There you go.
Now you're heading out of it.
No wonder my hopes and dreams are over.
That's fucking right.
When you get married, you can never have any more hopes and dreams.
Our child is our hopes and dreams now.
That's why we live like you said through the child.
Oh my god!
Yay!
Time to tell another story.
Yeah!
Time to give the child unrealistic expectations now!
Because my hopes and dreams are dead.
I'm okay by the way.
Wait.
Oh, we have to sing, okay.
Alright.
Yay!
I don't know where we have to go here.
Do I sing here?
Wait, where are you going?
Oh, here?
Oh, there is something here.
Woah!
Up we go!
Uh-oh.
This is not a hobby at that point.
How much money have you invested in this?
Is this where...
Like, there is way too many things here for a hobby.
Oh, how do we do this?
Yeah, try this.
Trust me.
Oh, it's like I'm fucking Marshmallow!
Drop the bass.
I don't know how Marshmallow does it.
I'm coming down.
Are you ready for the drop?
Have you seen that TikTok video of like 19...
Like the 1920s...
Dance Club remix?
Hold on, hold on, hold on!
Oh god!
Woah, woah.
Don't worry, DJ Doki is here.
Woah!
This is trippy.
Oh my god!
How do I...
Okay.
Wait, what?
Oh!
The top was too...
It's okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then you jump here.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, right there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Jump, jump.
And then...
Oh!
I went the wrong way, but it's okay.
I went the right way now.
The right, right way.
Okay.
There you go.
What the hell is happening?
That shit is trippy.
I like that mechanic.
You've seen Osmosis Jones?
Yeah!
Alright.
Let me use it.
No, I'm not high enough.
I'm not high enough.
I'm good.
Alright.
Turn on.
Oh, we're recording!
Get ready to sing!
lol Mogu nothing,
there.
Goodbye, your hopes and dreams.
No more singing for you.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Oh, he angy.
Oh!
You sing to it!
It's...
Oh!
You sing to it!
Oh, you're like a snake charmer!
Go up.
Oh, they're like little snakes!
We're gonna kill your love.
We're gonna kill all your dreams here.
Oh, it moved!
Wait, you need to sing to it.
You need to sing to it.
He's on me!
I'm too far!
I'm dead.
Where am I going?
Am I dead forever?
No.
Oh, okay.
Alright, I'm gonna push you over.
You need to keep singing to it.
Keep singing to it!
I'm running out!
I need you to sing to it!
He's looking at me!
Alright, he's dead.
Alright.
I got bored.
I know you did.
Wee!
Oh, there's one above us!
Sing!
What the fuck?
Why can't I... Wait, keep singing?
Oh yeah, I got it.
Wouldn't these spikes not hurt us?
Oh, they do hurt us.
They're made of foam!
Why would these spikes hurt?
It's literally foam!
Please don't stop me!
Okay, nice.
You have to keep singing though.
The snakes wanna hurt us.
What?
How?
Hello.
I'm...
Well, I hope you're doing okay.
Because I might be stuck here.
I don't think there's a way for me to get back over.
Is there?
Oh, no.
No, you just have to die.
You have to die and come back.
Cause I'm literally soft locked here.
Oh my god.
I'm stuck here!
Oh no!
No!
Wait, you can come back!
Okay!
Oh my god.
This is a group effort.
All I'm saying.
Okay, let me recharge my CPC real quick.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Look at that!
See!
Look, it's not my fault.
This is a group effort.
I'm recharging.
Alright.
I'm gonna go up.
I'm here.
Everything's fine.
Alright, you ready?
Uh-huh.
What the fuck?
Oh!
Don't worry, I'm coming back.
I thought the thing was behind us.
Oh!
Fuck!
I thought you were there, but it's okay.
I'm coming back.
I've just fed the snake again.
Oh god.
We did it.
As a team.
Oh!
What was that?
Oh, big snake!
Dude, this is such a cool design though.
Yeah, that is a cool... like, that's so creative for making it a snake.
Oh no.
Oh fuck.
Oh no, it's Crash Bandicoot again.
It's Crash Bandicoot.
Okay, the amount of fucking money we have spent on these microphones though.
I think we need to talk about where you got this money from.
I worked for it.
Yeah, but like, do you not care about our daughter's college tuition?
I-I put in savings.
Dude, do you not care?
What about you?
Do you not care?
What about me?
Why aren't you picking up another job?
What do you mean another job?
If you care so much, why don't you pick up a job?
What do you mean?
Instead of paying attention to Joy all day.
Housework is a job!
I literally took care of our... look at you, I died.
She has school!
Who's gonna take care of the house?
You come home at 9 PM everyday.
What the fuck?
I didn't even see that sign.
I'm having my breathing thanks.
Oh, he's getting closer.
All I'm saying is that you come home so fucking late.
Like, what am I supposed to do?
I can't get a job if you're gonna not be at home.
Oh, not gonna say anything, huh?
Not gonna say anything.
What the fuck?
I didn't know that.
Why else would I have the jukebox?
That's your grandfather's, man.
Oh, sorry.
I see my grandfather as my dad.
Because my dad left.
Two incomes are better than one.
Make Doki work two jobs.
Yeah.
Farming is a job!
Did you say gardening?
And you earn...
Oh.
That's a good job.
Oh, shit.
But they're all like cut up.
That's not... what?
Seeing kill my grandparents.
I didn't kill your grandparents!
Seeing kill my grandparents!
What's this?
What?
Oh!
That's a hit, yo.
That's it, right?
Oh, we have to do more?
Oh, we have to add more!
Oh, there we go.
We got it.
We're good.
Oh, there we go.
We got it.
We're good.
Oh, look at that sick-ass fucking beat.
Yeah, we made that.
We made that.
Yeah, what is our name?
We're not a hit, but it's music.
Daft Punk.
Okay, well, I think that's copyright infringement.
No, because it's funk, not punk.
It's like bunk beds.
We share bunk beds, so we're daft bunk.
Like our...
Our performance appearance, it's like a bunk bed.
So you're on the top.
Yeah, you're on the top.
I'm on the top of the bunk bed, you're on the bottom of the bunk bed.
And we DJ from there.
Like the beds are like our DJ platforms.
Like the DJ equipment.
And then we're like the daft bunks.
Because we use...
It's so smart!
It'll be so cool!
People are gonna love it!
And then we can sell like bunk beds as our like... as our product.
As our brand.
That
sounds lame!
You don't know art.
You don't know creativity.
Hey look, that spotlight must be for you.
Uh, no thanks.
Come on, man.
You deserve to be in the spotlight.
Daft bunk, y'all.
Now get down there.
Okay, okay.
I guess it's my time to shine.
It's my turn to be a star, baby.
Hey, hey, hey!
Lights on me!
Ow, ow, ow, ow!
I can get hurt if I'm not the center of the attention.
I've got you covered, Kofi!
Keep going!
Pay attention to me or I'll be the center of the attention.
I'll get hurt.
Alright.
Right side.
Okay, center.
Ow.
Is it desync or something?
What the fuck?
How do I get across from that?
Wait, there's something here.
Oh yeah, there is.
Okay, ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Go.
Keep going.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, we have to move the other one.
Trust me!
I can handle it!
Yeah, you have to.
Wait.
How do we get to the other side?
You have to look at it.
Oh wait!
You have to go look at it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That light is the platform.
Alright.
Come on, be faster than me.
Oh.
Is there desync or something?
What's going on?
I have no idea.
Where's your other light?
Okay, stay right there.
Yeah.
Alright, you have to go get the left side.
The left side.
I know, this light can only go left.
The red one can only go right.
Oh, okay.
And then...
Nice.
I'm heading over.
Alright, I'm going to go super fast.
Watch this.
Oh, now you go super fast!
Now!
Alright, chase after me.
Hey, I see a light switch!
Alright, turn it on.
Now.
Dude, I think there was actual desync because I was on you the entire time and you still kept getting hurt.
Yeah, yeah, because you were not on me on my screen.
On my screen, I was directly on you.
Yeah, but I'm host.
I guess that's what happened with the grass too.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, that should make sense.
What the hell?
Oh my god!
Oh, you're going to sing!
You know how...
My taste in music is like... metal.
Yeah.
Um...
Dude, I fucking love being at the barricades.
But I also hate it at the same time.
Won't you get pushed against it?
Oh yeah, you mosh.
Yeah.
I only go to concerts if I can get VIP and I can like...
enter in early to get towards the barricades or else I'm not really going.
Now!
Go and find an orchestra!
Can you not encourage him, please?
Okay, okay.
If you sing.
Oh my god!
Are you ready to sing in front of everybody?
This is it!
Your hopes and dreams!
I'm not a pa- Wait, is this chess?
Is this actual chess?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is actual chess.
Wait, wait.
Hey, can we do...
We're not playing fucking...
We're not doing quick.
There's no way.
Not other... Okay.
I haven't played chess in a long time.
So I don't know what I'm doing.
How do we make it quick?
Oh!
What if I just copy your every move?
What is wrong with you?
What if I just copy your...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm not thinking any steps ahead.
I'm not either.
I'm just moving.
Me too.
I just want to play.
I just move.
I just wanted to get the horse out.
Me too!
The horsey!
Ney!
You want my horsey?
Then your horsey be friends?
Yeah.
No.
That's not so friendly.
Of course.
What if I don't want your horsey to be friends with my horsey?
Hello?
Can I get this one?
Here she goes.
Do do do do.
I want to move this horse.
This way.
I wanna move my horsey.
Oh my god.
They can kiss you.
They so close.
What the fuck?
You didn't even move your horsey.
What if they don't move like that?
You lied to me.
I hope so.
I'm gonna make the king attack you.
What the hell?
The king is coming head over.
But what if the king just walks up to you and just... wouldn't it be funny if I just lose my queen right here?
That would be so fucking hilarious.
If I just lose my queen right there.
That would be so funny.
I'd be like he he ha ha.
I want my horse to go here.
And I...
I want my...
my king to stay right here and just look at you.
Alright.
Okay.
Just look at you like that.
Just look at you.
Okay.
This one.
A little look.
I know he's gonna stare at you.
Okay.
He's just looking at you like that.
And just like hello.
Okay.
Isn't that cute?
Isn't that funny?
I heard you the first time.
Wouldn't that be so funny?
Weren't you in the chess club or something?
Yeah, but I don't care anymore.
I don't think when I play chess anymore.
Because I don't play chess anymore.
I've never played...
I learned how to play chess from the computer.
I don't play chess anymore so I don't really care.
You know what?
I'm just gonna eat your horse.
You can eat my pawn.
But like I got your horse.
Wait, I left my horse there because you said our horses were friends.
Well, is this a horse?
Is this a horse?
What the hell?
I mean, you're just gonna eat a pawn.
So who cares?
Whoa!
That's fucked up!
Why would you do that?
It's just a little horse.
I won't tell you.
Where is my king?
Literally looking at it.
Where's my king?
I'm literally looking at it.
I thought you were like, I'm gonna put my king here.
I'm gonna put my king here so it looks at you.
Because I want my king to look at you.
Where is it?
That's all you come saying.
I want my king to look at you.
Yeah, because I want to look at you.
I want to be like...
See, look, I exchanged my horse for your horse.
Because I was being nice.
I was like... Yeah, you mean?
Yeah, I gave you my horse because I wanted to be nice.
You mean that too?
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Don't yawn.
I mean, what the fuck?
Why did you move your castle there?
That's fucked up.
Why did you do that?
Why did you move your castle over there?
That's mean.
Because I want to.
Why?
Why would you want that?
Because I want to.
Why?
Why would you want that though?
Because I want to.
Why?
I forgot how to tag me.
I forgot.
You can't go to the stand there like that.
What are you saying?
I forgot how to tag me.
I was just fucking around.
This is supposed to be a quick game that I'm messing about.
Oh, there's your queen over there.
There she is.
She's over here.
Are you gonna move your bishop?
Yeah, I'm moving my bishop over here.
Okay.
I'm gonna move this one.
Not that one.
And then I'm gonna move it right here.
Okay.
You move over there.
And then I'm gonna move...
I'm gonna move her...
over...
Where do I go?
You only have a minute and twenty seconds.
I know.
Stop me.
I got me you son of a bitch.
You think you're so smart.
Where are you gonna move?
I want my horse.
No.
Not here.
That's fucked up.
Why did you move over there?
I wanted to be there.
But why?
Why did you want it to be there?
What purpose does it give you?
I just wanted it there.
I'm impressed by myself.
Why would you do that?
No, not checked.
I'm JK.
What do you mean checked?
I thought this king was over here.
I wasn't looking.
JK, hee hee.
That was not checked.
JK, I think I was just joking.
Hee hee.
Hee hee funny.
Wasn't that funny that I thought that was checked?
Shut up dude.
Yeah, that was kind of funny.
That was pretty hee hee.
Wasn't that hilarious?
Yeah, that was kind of funny.
Hee hee.
Where do I want to go?
Home.
You don't know where to go.
I don't know.
Why don't you think for like one more minute?
Just think for one more minute, you know?
I think I might move home.
Why did you go home?
Just think for one more minute.
I wanted to go home.
Why did you go home?
Just keep thinking.
I wanted to.
Hee hee.
I'll go here then.
Okay.
Woah, woah, woah.
Hello.
I want to send my horse home too.
Why are you sending your horse home?
Your horse just wants to have fun.
You know?
You ate my other horse.
Woah.
You actually have...
10 seconds left.
9, 8, 7, 6.
I've said seconds.
I can still do stuff.
Okay, I'm putting my horse here.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna eat your pawn anyway.
Because I have 4 seconds.
There you go.
That's fine.
I got...
What?
Do you have more time?
Wait, I thought it was like more pieces.
But I ate more pieces, didn't I?
No.
I have more time.
Didn't I eat more pieces?
Wait, it's...
It's like whoever runs out of time...
Oh!
You need to lose.
Oh my god, it's Heaven's Gate.
Oh shit.
Your singing's not that good.
The fuck?
Oh, it's time or checkmate.
Oh, more instruments.
Yeah, you just got beat by a person who learned how to play from a computer.
All this stuff brings back some good memories.
From running out of time.
That is... wait, were we out of heaven?
Bro, that was fast.
We're not in heaven anymore apparently.
There's a...
What's this?
Yeah, but don't drink the wine.
Don't drink the wine.
Wow, that's a lot of wine.
You're a wine mom.
Oh, there's a picture.
I don't like wine that much.
Wait, wait, wait.
Where is it?
Look at that!
I can play Twinkle Twinkle Little Star!
I thought you were playing Mary Had a Little Lamb.
Oh, it's actually the same tune.
Mary Had a...
Isn't it Twinkle... no, there's like...
Row, row, row your boat.
Gently down the stream.
There's like... there's like tunes that are like basically the same tune.
And then it's like...
What are you doing?
I'm waiting for you.
How do I get there?
Go down.
Go down?
Oh, you're downstairs!
I thought you were above me.
No.
There's something here.
But I'm over here.
And now I'm over here.
Now I'm back.
Alright, I'm ready.
Yay!
Yippee!
We're so smart together.
What did that do?
I don't know.
Oh, I sent you the vines.
Oh!
Yes, sir.
Three bags full.
What the fuck?
Whoa, what's this?
You have an accordion?
Oh!
It kills you.
What's that machine?
Looks like some kind of accordion.
How do we fucking...
Do you sing... can you sing against it?
Oh, I can shield!
Guys, remember when I have a shield?
I got this.
Follow me.
M'lady.
You have to stand behind my shield.
I'm worth something now.
Oh!
Oh my god!
That's sick!
I'm blocked!
Right side.
To the right.
Here we go.
We're good.
We just run past it.
Chivalry is not dead, exactly.
But some...
I don't even need her to say thank you.
I mean, it would be nice, you know?
Don't you say so?
Oh, yeah.
To the left side.
Left!
Right!
Okay, I got it.
It should stay open now.
Yeah.
Here I go.
I'm going to wait for you.
Wee!
No, I don't.
I can just be here.
Oh, I need to go to the other side.
May!
You need to jump off my head.
The final stop.
I don't need the little notes come off the paper.
Oh, yeah!
That's so cute!
I like that.
Yay!
Where the fuck are we?
Are we in a cello or something?
How much music do you play?
How do we have all these instruments?
Are we back in music heaven?
Dude, why the fuck are we in heaven?
Because we're good people?
Well, obviously I think I'm a good person.
I gave you my pass.
I gave you my plus one.
Okay, sure.
Lying is a sin, you know.
Yeah.
That's why I gave you my pass.
And why you're not in heaven.
What?
What kind of concert is this?
I thought this was a pop concert.
They've been kidnapped?
Like the devils?
You have to go and save the orchestra!
Go?
How?
We don't walk on clouds!
Aren't we technically walking on...
Oh, okay.
I thought we were already on clouds.
Now you can.
Go, go, go!
Alright.
Time to kill the devils!
Wait, but where do we go?
Go here?
Oh my god, there's flying pigs!
Oh my god, when pigs fly!
But what are the music notes for?
Oh, we have to get all the music notes!
Why do I get the cutscene and you don't?
I got the cutscene before you!
Wait, then why do I have to watch it again?
Alright, just a few more bubbles to pop!
Once you pop, you can't stop!
We get all the ones here?
No, we're missing one.
Oh, it's up here.
I got one of the doors up.
Oh my god, I see the devils!
Come on!
Wait, can I kill the pigs?
Oh my god!
Stop!
Wait, there's tennis!
There's tennis!
Oh, volleyball!
I love volleyball!
Okay, jump is nice.
Why, it scared you?
Oh my god, look!
It's a devil bat!
Yeah, it's a devil bat!
It's a devil and a pig.
The angels are pigs?
That's funny.
The angels are pigs.
Wait, this is not real volleyball!
This is not regular volleyball!
How dare they tarnish volleyball!
I can't believe it.
Not my volleyball.
What?!
Okay.
Not my volleyball.
Oh my god.
Dude!
I know, it gets confusing when there's two.
Nice.
Alright.
Woo!
Yeah!
I wish you made it more clear that you were under it.
It's like...
It's so weird.
Because it's hard to see where the ball is going to land too.
I think that's like...
the more frustrating part.
Yeah.
It's...
What?!
That was clear!
I hate this game.
It ruined volleyball for me.
I'm a tailpull!
I told you!
This sucks!
What?!
You got tailpulled!
You get to hit balls?!
Nice kill!
Oh god.
Bro.
It's getting harder.
It's going harder.
What?!
Okay.
Oh,
out of here!
Oh god.
No!
Bro!
The dog!
Oh, it's breaking the game!
This is it.
Dude, fuck these pigs.
Down with all the angel pigs!
Come on!
Where are they?
I'm coming over!
No!
I can't kill him!
Where are you adorable pigs?
I'm coming over!
No, I can't get rid of them.
I'll pet you.
I guess I'll pet you.
Wait, they're not pigs!
They're like little hamsters.
Yeah, what the heck?
Yeah!
They're little hamsters.
Oh my god, his face is so cute!
Look at his little paws!
Yeah, he has little paw pads too.
He's not gonna stop me from eliminating him.
I can pet this one too.
Stop!
They ruined volleyball!
They didn't do shit!
We're the devils!
I'm waiting for you on the other side.
Well, I'm clearing out the music net so we can just get out of the way.
We're gonna head there eventually anyway.
I'm right here with the devil here.
Oh yeah, get that KD ratio up.
You're right.
You sweet... you're a fucking dick.
Oh, woah, why do they have faces?
Where's the orchestra?
Bro, ugh.
We'll never find them!
Guy?
That one's throwing ass.
Oh!
Sorry, Cloud.
My bad.
No, wait!
Look!
He's crying!
Are those our...
guys?
Those voice actors are so...
I feel like I know them.
The voice actors.
They're so recognizable.
So I just have to beat up the clouds.
That's easy.
Okay.
Sorry, Clouds!
You need your tears to clear the fog!
Don't worry.
I'm making them all cry!
They like it!
They're tears of joy!
Oh, I pushed the clouds over!
Oh, you pushed them over!
So I've been beating up for no reason.
Stop beating this one's ass, dude!
I just look over and this is Cloud's extra size!
What if they like it?
You don't know that!
Is that why they're crying and look so sad?
They like it!
They're tears of jo- Okay, it's like those like...
They're tears of joy!
I'm pretty sure I just heard this one say, Oh no, no, no!
I think you're supposed to move them around so like...
we- it clears the fog, right?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure you're supposed to- All the fogs?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure you're supposed to clear the fog.
Yeah, see?
Do you hear it?
It's going- Tears of happiness.
I hear those tears of happiness right there.
Oh, there it is!
We have to- Here, here!
There they are!
We gotta beat them!
Beat them up!
Here we go.
I got one!
Where's the last guy?
I got two.
Where's the last one?
Was there three?
I thought there was three.
No, there was only two!
Cause they had two keys.
Oh!
But where's the key then?
I think we have to get the cloud thing up.
I think we have to make sure the fog is still clear.
Cause I don't see any keys.
Where the fuck- Don't worry, I got you.
Oh my god.
He looks so miserable.
He looks so happy.
Oh, there it is!
I knew there was one more.
Yeah, there's the other one!
I got it!
Wait, where's the other key then?
Wait, do you have- Do you have one on the floor somewhere?
Yeah, you must have dropped it on the floor.
Cause where is it?
Where's the last key?
It has to be like in the fog somewhere.
Oh wait!
There's a guy!
Oh, there he is!
I didn't even see him.
Do I have it?
Stop!
Dragoon, you like that Dragoon?
What the heck?
Get over here!
I'm here!
Let me save one of them.
Let me get the other half of the orchestra.
You think they're dead people?
We are in heaven.
Oh my god, that could be Mozart right there!
Let's get to the other side!
Yeah, we could've had Beethoven!
We could've had Beethoven!
I actually call him Motsi.
You're that close?
Yeah, yeah.
Beethoven, call him Bebe.
What?
I heard it blow up!
He's like, he's in heaven!
So like technically he's still alive.
Yeah, excuse me.
Devils?
Yeah, we're gonna need to borrow that orchestra that you got locked up in there.
We will never let them out!
I'm glad you also noticed that.
Yeah, yeah.
Woah!
We could just beat up all of them.
Okay, but what if we just hit everything?
Yeah, if I kill everybody, then we win.
Here, I got the key one.
I got the key.
Oh, I've just been killing all of them.
Yeah, me too honestly.
Okay, I'll grab this one though.
Woah, wait, they can steal from you?
Bro, that's fucked up!
Don't worry, I got another one.
That's fucked up as we're killing all of them?
Yeah, we're killing all your friends and family and you're just gonna focus on the key?
Yeah, wait, you already killed them.
I like how we killed all of them instead of the actual person with the key.
Well, they were gonna steal it anyways.
We did it!
Oh.
Why don't you say anything?
We're supposed to be a team!
It looked like you were having fun.
Yay!
Now we save Chopin!
Oh my god, reminds me of Sound of Music.
Is that it?
Now we need to get the Maestro.
You're the Maestro.
That's the whole of the thing.
I wonder if I can die.
Wait.
I'm gonna test the theory.
You can die.
Look, it's all about experimentation.
Leave it alone!
Wait,
what?
What did I do?
Dude, I'm so glad I saw one more on your screen too.
I just didn't want to tell you.
It'll be fine.
No, no, no, no, no.
It will not be fine.
He gets to go to double heaven.
It'll be fantastico!
Hyah!
Woah!
Rematch time.
I see the chest for...
What the fu- Good job!
We're almost ready.
The only thing missing is...
the audience.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Not an audience.
Hyah!
Do you want the last letter piece or not?
Hey, that's blackmail.
No!
That's manipulation.
Now go and get the fuck...
Blackmail in a relationship... No, but you had a point earlier.
is a healthy relationship.
I didn't get to, like, reply earlier, but you were right.
There are some marriages that are, like, that need to be ended.
Yeah.
Like, you can't fix all marriages.
This is one of them.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, VIP!
We're VIP!
That's us!
Let us in!
Hey, buddy, over here!
What's up?
Can you let us in?
Sorry, kids.
No minors.
Kids?
No, no, no, no.
We're just, uh... Yeah.
We're small in size, that's all.
I can't believe it.
Just cause we're small?
Get out of here, you dosed.
Excuse me, we are adults.
You have some ID?
Oh, uh, no.
We left it at home.
That's what they all say.
Yo, yo!
Glowstick!
There with me!
Dr. Akeem, my bro!
There with you?
God, douchebags stick together.
Sorry about that.
Welcome to the club.
Enjoy the evening.
VIP's coming through.
Not so cocky anymore, are ya?
Huh?
Yeah, fucking yell at the body.
Yell at the fucking bouncer.
That's a good idea.
That's you, man.
Oh my god, Rainbow Road!
The tender's coming.
What?
Here we go.
This is surreal.
I call left.
It's already going right, man.
Oh my god, it is!
It's literally Mario Kart!
They're like, if you fall off, you get the...
Wait a minute.
Yeah, look!
Oh my god!
I'm telling you, Ten.
Pal world and now this?
Statistics, do they never learn?
Who to the left?
Where?
Everything you own in a box to the left.
Catch up, ladies!
More fun together!
In the bedroom.
Please don't leave.
Still in the front.
What the fuck?
I died to experience it, man.
No one told you to die.
Come on.
You could have just looked at my screen.
I don't screen peek.
Yeah, yeah, you don't screen peek.
You've been screen peeking since we started.
Oh my god, that's scary.
Yeah, or else you're gonna be like, Oh, Goomy, where's my context clues?
Oh, it's like those little, like the, the, the spring, what were they called?
Those little spiral things?
In the 90s?
Oh, the slinkies?
Slinkies, yeah!
You know there's people who do, like, play with slinkies as a job?
I've seen people do that.
Like magic tricks and stuff.
Like, have you seen like those, like, But it's like a job or something.
Because people hire them for party entertainment.
Yeah.
Slinkies?
Yeah!
I saw like a fucking YouTube short of it.
They, like, people, like, They get hired or some shit to like, Do like slinky tricks.
Yeah, slinky artists.
What the fuck?
Why am I stuck on this side?
Oh god, this is really annoying.
Okay.
This is so annoying.
Actually.
Yeah, anything can be a job if there's a demand.
That's true.
Come for me, you're a lovely husband.
I need to press that?
Are you fucking...
Really?
He opened that and you're all about me?
Oh, I need you there.
Open, open, open sesame!
Open sesame!
Oh...
I watched it, please.
I'm here anyway.
What's this?
Where in the area that they like...
Make the...
Make the disco ball.
Yeah, with the disco ball.
I can do this to you.
Boom.
Oh my god.
Wait, no, my symbol!
Forget it, Cody!
No!
My lady!
Move it, move it!
Dance dance, Cody!
Do I have to move anywhere?
Oh, wait.
Wait, I don't.
No, I do!
I thought you just stand there.
I thought you learned from the first time, but you just didn't.
I couldn't tell.
My perception.
My depth perception was off.
Because he's moving still.
So I assume he's moving for me.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Woo!
Holy shit, how long is this road?
I thought we just had to do...
Oh!
I thought... Oh shit!
I thought we just had to do an orchestra.
Why is your hobby and passion so long and complicated?
Oh my god!
Oh, it's okay.
You're still alive.
I'll just wait.
You can do this.
I believe in you.
When you don't press anything, it auto-presses for you.
I know.
I've heard that one time you kept dying on purpose.
Not even on purpose.
I remember you just kept dying!
Check this place out.
Wow, this is cool.
Wait, this is Da Punk!
Oh, look at our line trails!
There's colors behind us.
You know this script hands down the weirdest experience of my life?
What's that one movie?
I'm glad I didn't have to do it alone.
What?
Tron.
Yeah, Tron!
I love Tron.
They're making a sequel.
I never watched it.
Why not?
A jellyfish!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
This is trippy.
Wait, where's the jellyfish?
No!
I was looking at the fucking glow!
Oh my god!
That's mean when I go to my concert.
Oh!
They don't like us?
What do we do?
Stop the music.
Okay, baby!
Groovin'!
No, they're leaving!
We're killing the vibes!
Can't be me.
I like Da Punk.
Play some music!
Make them dance!
Maybe they will if you leave the dance floor.
Yeah, dude.
Seriously.
I think you're scaring them.
No way, baby!
I'm killing it!
Can't you see my hip gyration?
Please stop.
Not again!
Oh my god!
Look at this!
Right, left, right, left, left!
But!
To make the audience dance, you need to play the music!
Get the audience on the floor!
Let's DJ, baby!
I don't know.
If this guy tells me to say all that, I don't think I want to be at the club anymore.
I don't think I want to be at the club anymore.
Ehh.
How do we do this?
Let's figure out this DJ thing!
Oh!
Do it!
Make them dance!
That's it!
You just spin the thing?
Oh my god!
That's all they need?
A fog machine?
So they can't see what's going on in front of them?
No consequences when you can't see!
Is that it?
If there's no consequences, if you don't know what's happening...
Oh, this one.
You have to dance!
You have to go to the circle and dance too!
Oh, we have to do this.
I'm turning the thing!
I'm turning it!
There you go.
Oh my god, we're doing it!
Now we dance!
Look at us go!
Oh my god, it's time to actually dance.
Dance as Revolution.
I used to have those dance pads.
I had a Mario one.
There's a Mario one?
Oh, we have to do all of this now.
Oh my god.
Defy the fire, Doki!
Defy the fire!
I'm trying!
Oh no, they can see the consequences of their actions!
They need more fun!
They don't want to know what's going on!
Yeah, DJ Cody's here.
Yeah, it's totally not cringe.
Oh, my god.
Look at the crowd!
They're dancing for us!
What the fuck?!
What the fuck is he doing?
That's fucked up!
You spin me round You spin me round You spin me round You spin me round He plays
music and stuff.
He plays music and stuff.
Oh, I missed the fucking...
Ow!
How do you hit all of them?
I'm hitting the music.
I'm riding the music.
Oh my god, how are you so fucking fast?
I don't know.
How are you doing that?
Are you cheating?
What do you mean am I cheating?
I'm cheating!
There's no way.
It can't be because I keep hitting every obstacle.
Oh my god, I'm being a joke.
Can't wait to see what that looks like.
Absolutely incredible.
I can't believe it made you skip ahead to the cutscene I'm at.
No, I just made it!
Whoa.
I was right beside you this entire time.
Uh-huh.
360.
Oh, that's so great.
Holy shit.
That's so great.
Yeah!
Look at that audience!
Dude, you kidnapped them from the club.
Are you ready for your performance?
They're just heading to the afterparty.
Uh, um, are we still missing something?
No!
We got everything we need!
Everything?
It's showtime, baby!
Woo!
You hear that, Mae?
You hear the anticipation?
I haven't performed in front of an audience for ages.
Mae, it'll be fine.
Just, uh, just think of them all in their underwear.
Yes.
That would make you relax.
Got it.
Let's go prep the stage.
Okay, Buck.
Hey, Mae.
Break a leg.
Yeah.
Break both legs and your arms.
What the fuck?
What?
It's for good luck!
I don't think so.
The more bones you break, the more luck you get.
That's our show business.
I don't know if that's true.
Then why do you tell people to break the legs?
Just seeing from your height.
I don't... I don't know.
Yeah!
You were born to be...
Break your arms and legs and your back.
You were born to be you, he said.
Wait, is it just you?
What the fuck?
I don't get to play the game now?
What about me?
What are you doing?
Flight of the Barnes.
What would be... Oh, it would be so funny if that was to kill the Mockingjay.
Mockingjay?
Yeah, Mockingbird.
Can you only walk?
Yeah, I can only walk.
It doesn't even let me crouch or anything.
Lily Fields.
Sing from the heart.
Sing from the heart, Gumi.
That's so nice.
I don't have to play the video game.
I get to do a watch-along.
It's Reacts content time!
Doki reacts to Gumi.
Oh my god.
Gumi's gameplay.
Oh my god, what is Gumi gonna do now?
What the fuck is that?
Is that me?
Oh shit!
Oh, it's you!
It's your turn!
Gumi reacts to... What do I have to say?
This isn't my dream and hopes.
Am I just walking too?
Look at all these people here for you.
There has to be at least 5,000 people there.
That does not look 5,000.
That looks like maybe 130.
That looks at least like 10,000 people in the audience.
No pressure.
What?
Oh shit!
Doki reacts.
Alright, so Gumi's gonna walk straight in the line.
I wonder what's gonna happen.
Chat?
I'm actually turning.
She's gonna start turning?
Oh, I think I got chat.
I think she's heading to the stage that we just saw earlier.
Hahaha!
Vehicle maintenance.
Oh, those are my books!
That's my shit!
Classic children's stories.
Oh, you're gonna start playing!
Wait, are you even gonna sing?
Or is it maestro time?
Oh my god, it's the concert getting ready.
Oh my god!
They're all here for you!
They don't have eyes so they can't see if it's a bad performance.
Dude, they were kidnapped.
They were literally kidnapped to be here.
I believe in you.
Come on!
They have to clap.
If they don't clap, they stay here forever.
They can't go home to their families.
Oh yeah, the daughter.
I almost forgot about her.
She's like...
What's going on?
It's been like... eight hours now.
Dinner was supposed to be ready an hour ago.
Mom?
Dad?
Are you guys just...
There's this... another attic!
Mom?
Dad?
The music just started playing in the attic above us.
Are there people that like... you know...
Do we have ghosts?
I thought... I thought it was just us three.
Mom, wake up!
Mom, look!
Look what I found, Mom!
The sun is setting now!
Mom?
Mommy...
I found your favorite song.
Shut up!
I'm sleeping!
Oh... shit...
Oh my god!
This is so sad for the child!
She has so many issues right now!
Like both their parents are unresponsive.
And like, I'm giving you my heart mom, I love you.
And then mom's just like, don't know wald.
Sing anaconda!
My anaconda don't, my anaconda don't, my anaconda don't want none.
Okay, to be fair, this audience is not there for classic music.
Like this is a rave audience.
We have the wrong fucking fans here.
Bro they're so fucking boring.
Where are the words?
Where are the beats?
We are flying.
Are we gonna kiss?
Oh my god.
With the power of music?
Are our kids running away from home right now?
Marriage saved.
That was beautiful, Mae.
Thank you.
I do.
What?
Hold.
We're actually gonna, no, fly away.
Fly away.
No!
Don't!
Let go!
Oh, I can back away from you.
I can...
Oh my god.
We stared deeply into each other's eyes.
Clink.
Oh, but what if I don't?
That's right.
I'm getting the ick.
I'm getting the ick right now.
Unless I haven't finished the scene.
I'm getting the ick.
Okay.
Slow and steady.
And I go straight in.
But what if I stop?
Oh, it won't let me.
Please, I'm getting the ick!
And then I stop.
Just close your fucking eyes and go ahead!
Just the two of us...
Just the two of us... I'm gonna stare deep into your eyes!
My controller is vibing!
My crazy table!
Guys, here, this is...
This is the sound of the controller.
Oh my god!
It's right there!
See, first it lives!
He's like, get closer!
Get closer!
Whoa...
Almost there!
Almost...
Bro!
There you go.
Wait, is that even a kiss yet?
Cause I didn't close my eyes!
Please!
I like saw two different X's in the time frame!
Hahaha!
Wait!
It's the slow burn!
Don't you like slow burn?
Oh god...
That was like 130 chapters in.
Hahaha!
This is it!
Oh no...
No, this is Stockholm Syndrome taking effect right now.
Singing a song!
This is just miraculously fucking fixing marriage!
There are underlying issues!
Hahaha!
Look at that!
So beautiful!
Ew, he's like, nodding over it.
Hahaha!
He's like, ugh!
Stop!
Oh my god, this guy watched this five minute kiss that we had.
There's like underlying issues that we have in this marriage!
Fucking singing wouldn't fix this!
Oh my god, we're normal!
We're normal people now!
World's greatest dad!
As me!
We're sure world's greatest mom!
Oh my god, wait, look at our computer!
What?
What's that on the computer?
We are back in the 90's!
Oh, this is the 90's?
We're like back in the early 2000's!
What the fuck?
Look how clear it is outside!
Where do we live?
I mean, we're on the farm!
Rose!
Cody!
May!
It works!
Oh, I was like sleeping in a different... Am I taller than you?
Yes you are.
Short king.
I don't know.
Hahaha!
Rose?
Peace, Papu.
Just throw it in the trash.
Hahaha!
Rose ran away while we're dealing with our problems.
Dear mom and dad...
Hey!
What?
The letter.
We didn't even read the letter?
Dear mom and dad...
I'm sorry that I did this to you.
That's right.
I know how to make everything good again.
Oh my god!
All I have to do is stop fighting.
I know I'm not a perfect daughter.
No!
I'm sorry I don't like to brush my teeth.
Bro, what the fuck is wrong with you?
I'm sorry I didn't have a good time.
I'm sorry I don't put my toys where they should be.
I know it's my fault you wanted to fight.
She's blaming herself.
That's her fault.
And she's right.
No, I'm just joking about that.
You should be friends.
I love you, mom.
Mom and dad are really good friends.
P.S.
I have pocket money to buy a bus ticket.
Don't worry.
I packed a sandwich and a lollipop.
What the fuck?
She's gonna die out there.
Brode!
What are you doing after the bus, child?
Where's our car?
Do we not have a car?
What was all that oil for?
I'm not gonna talk about it.
What happened to her?
She already took the bus and we're just running.
You can go home.
No.
Honey, it's not your fault that we've been fighting.
It isn't.
No, Rose.
When we ignored you after you tried to call for us for five plus hours, it's not your fault.
We weren't ignoring you.
We might have ghosts in our house, but like you said, you can become friends again.
Here now.
Honey, listen.
Whatever happens, your mom and me...
Rose, listen.
If we're not friends, that means you get two birthdays.
And two Christmases.
That's fun.
Come here.
Oh shit.
Hey, throw that shit away.
Burn the book.
Why the fuck did she bring that shit with her?
What's wrong with you?
Where did you find this?
I found it at school.
In a trash can.
What?
In a trash can?
Find real treasures in the trash.
There's a reason why it's in the trash.
It's fucking cursed.
It's a cursed book.
How come there's a kid digging through the trash can in the first place?
I bet it was you.
I bet you taught her that.
What the fuck?
If your mom had to fight an aggressive squirrel double her size, who do you think would win?
Mom, of course.
Did we literally fix our marriage?
You're right.
I'm realistic.
That's unrealistic.
I think you are completely irrational.
But I have to say, you make more sense now.
We did it!
Oh my god, there's the sucker.
Oh my god, and the hammer and the weird toolbox.
Yeah.
Oh, there's whoever's fucking binoculars that is.
Whoever we're looking at, that's directed at our house.
We did it!
We beat the game!
Look, she's fixed now!
See?
We're not fucked up parents.
We fixed her.
Oh, and the clock.
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
Go away.
Oh, and the clock.
We did it!
Oh my god, there's the fat bee.
Yeah, remember?
That's the one that ditched us.
Yeah.
That somehow never got shot.
Why did she put it so high up?
That's her god now.
Thank you for fixing the marriage.
They're friends again.
Yeah, very good friends.
The book of love.
Yeah!
I still can't believe, like, we got, like, rave slash...
What the fuck did you pause for?
Dude, this is so fucking loud.
I just can't believe we got, like, the rave club people to be your audience for fucking classical music.
That is, like, the most unrealistic part of this game.
Dude, thank you.
I remember we came from a club that was like, go way back in the club, got our pickups, dropped the beat, and now I'm going, ahhhh.
I'm just like, I don't think they were here for this.
They waited in line, dude.
Those people waited in line to get into that club.
And then they fucking got dragged to your fucking classical music concert.
Like...
Dude, that person's name is Uno Byte.
Uno Byte?
What did I just read?
What?
Uno Byte... Is there an after credits scene, chat?
Yeah, they got scammed in the club.
Is there an after- wait, this game was made in Europe?
Which country?
Who made this?
Ohhhhhhhhhhhhh.
Frozen 2.
Unreal Engine.
I think it was really creative though.
This game was very creative with the mechanics and everything.
I love the- I think the level design was really pretty in general.
Like I definitely- I came into this game really blind.
The only thing I remember was the math and the beginning.
Like, what they look like.
Sweden?
Oh, it was made by the Swedes!
Oh!
I'm surprised, like, it was...
You know how, like, Sweden is, like, super fucking...
What is it?
Very cloudy and stuff?
I'm surprised that it was, like, so sunny out there.
I've never, like, even looked over yonder.
Is there an after credits scene?
I don't remember.
I didn't check chat.
I don't know.
I was surprised.
I was like, I can see the sun in this game.
What?
Yeah?
There is?
No clue?
Oh, there is!
How do we skip that?
Do we skip it?
No, we can't.
Wait, we can!
Alright, I'm ready.
Do we skip?
Or nah?
I'll have to...
Alright, I'm gonna do it.
Wait, I need you to do it.
It's a group effort.
No, there isn't.
We're not supposed to skip!
Oh my god.
Invite me again!
Invite me again and just click the credits button!
There!
First credits!
Wait!
We have to watch!
Can we just look at the credits here?
Does it work?
No, it doesn't!
Wait!
What?
We have to fucking actually...
Oh my god!
How was I supposed to know?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna YouTube it.
I'm YouTubing.
Okay.
Alright.
It takes...
It takes two... You're gonna listen to it.
And...
Okay.
Alternate... After credits...
Credits C.
What is it?
The basement?
There isn't.
Yes, there is.
No, there isn't.
There's like a basement.
Is this the...
Wait, there isn't?
Were we lied to?
There isn't!
We got...
I can't believe it.
We actually... We actually got gas lit.
You just got one guide.
We got one guide.
We got multiple guides.
People were freaking out and was like, why did you skip?
Why did you skip?
Alright.
It's time to go fishing.
GG's.
Gumi.
Are you gonna go play Minecraft or TFT?
After TFT, I'm about to get eliminated.
Oh, shit.
You're in last place?
They eliminate like four to five people every day.
Oh, shit.
Are you last place?
Girl, what do you mean am I last place?
You said you might get eliminated.
Yeah, because everyone's climbing right now.
So, if I don't climb actively, I'll keep dropping because I'm in the same spot.
Oh.
Alright.
Good luck, Gumi.
You wanna play?
No, that's okay.
Good luck.
Bye.
Alright.
Good luck.
Wait.
What was the other one?
Chat, Donkey said she would play the other game with me.
No, no.
There's no other one.
The other game that they made?
No, it's just that it takes two.
This was like... it was that.
You can technically... but they've mistaken from two brothers with husband and wife.
There's no other game.
Guys, guys, there's no other game.
Chat.
I think you guys are like... you got like the...
Oh, a way out.
No, no, no.
It takes two.
Wait, Donkey is 80% off right now.
No, no, no, no, no.
That's like made by a fake studio.
You know, it's like Helldivers.
When Helldivers got released, another studio released Helldivers 2 to like pretend to be Helldivers 2.
So, people would fall for like the 80% off thing.
That's what they did.
For that.
That's... it's not the same studio.
You say something?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, have you... have you let your chat play Lurkbait yet?
Lurkbait?
What?
Yeah, Lurkbait.
What is that?
It's where you can let your viewers fish.
Wait, what?
Yeah, they can fish on stream.
Oh, I saw this on Twitter before.
Isn't this a Twitch interactive?
Yeah, it's on Twitch only.
Oh my God, I got Twitch partnered.
Oh, you did?
Yeah, I got Twitch partnered today.
They sent me like an email today being like, congratulations, you got Twitch partnered.
And like, like I sent it in an app, but like I didn't think I would get in because like I literally only streamed twice since I got back.
And then I got the email being like, congratulations, you're a Twitch partner.
And I literally wrote on the application because, you know, I don't know if you remember, but when you write like why you want to be a Twitch partner, you have to write like something.
And all I wrote was, please.
Oh my God.
I just wrote, please.
And I submitted it.
And you say, please.
I think I'm special case here.
I'm pretty sure due to my circumstances, they're like, you know what, we know who she is.
But yeah, I got it today.
I was so surprised.
I honestly didn't think they would give it to me because usually they're like, you have to be active on Twitch.
But yeah.
The pity part.
That's me.
You go.
See you for a way out.
In two weeks.
What?
See you for a way out in two weeks.
Wait, wait, wait.
We're going to go from married to brother.
I mean, it could have been brothers to married.
Yeah, we should have done it the other way around.
That would make more sense.
I mean, we can make up a... not make up.
It could be a prequel.
It's our prequel.
Before we were married, we were brothers.
We could be married and then find out we're brothers.
Oh, that's true.
But we're still together.
Yeah, we're not telling our kids.
As long as we don't tell our child.
No, my friend actually asked me that story.
They were like, okay, let's say you had a boyfriend or a husband and then you had a kid together.
And like, they're the most like perfect person in your entire life.
Like, they're exactly what you want.
You're so happy with them.
Whatever.
But then you find out you're related to them.
Yeah.
Do you break up with them and divorce them and also tell your kids or like... what?
I mean, that's what denial is for.
Okay.
That's...
Like... like...
All right, what will you do?
What will you do?
I have to think about it.
Like...
It doesn't hurt anybody.
Is that the most perfect person?
Well...
I mean, maybe the kid is like, genetically wise.
Because of inbreeding.
But...
As long as the child doesn't go forth and accidentally, you know, keep it in the family.
Yeah.
I think...
Yeah, no.
I think at that point...
As long as only...
If we're married...
As long as only like two people know and it's the parents, I don't think like...
Like, it's already done.
Like...
Everything...
Yeah.
And if they're the most perfect person ever...
Everything is already done.
So, it's like...
There's really nothing...
You can't take that away.
Like, it's already there.
The child's there.
The product of the inbreeding is there.
So...
Like...
If you suddenly split up, you have to explain to the child why that happened.
I mean, I guess you won't explain it to them until you're at your desk bed and be like, the child...
The child...
The reason why...
But we should...
The reason why you have so many problems with your health...
Is because...
Your father and I are actually...
Related...
Okay...
But the next thing, cause obviously...
...and then you die...
And then you die so you don't have to live with the guilt cause you're already dead.
As you tell them before, you don't have to live with the trauma after that.
But you're free.
You're dead already.
You don't have to worry.
Okay.
Wait.
Hold on.
I don't quite know the rules of like inbreeding and everything.
So it looks like we're...
No, no, we're not siblings.
What if we're like second cousins?
Does it make sense?
Is the genetic tree still as bad as siblings?
It's not as bad.
It's not as bad but it's still bad.
I know but...
No, I know it's bad but I...
No, I'm trying to see how many health problems the kid would have.
You're trying to find a degree of separation here.
You're trying to see which is the right amount of separation.
That would...
It's okay.
It's bad because you can't have like...
If a population goes at a certain amount of people...
If a population dies off to a certain amount...
There's no way for a population to continue.
Because at some point inbreeding is gonna start.
I don't remember what was the minimum.
But like every species needs a minimum requirement to prevent inbreeding.
So I'm gonna stop here.
So it doesn't matter.
It has to be incredibly split off.
So you don't fuck up the genetics.
It's 50, right?
Okay.
Is it 50?
Because I just want to know how fucked up this kid would be.
I mean...
Because like...
Eventually...
Okay.
Okay, I don't even...
Why are we like thinking about the degrees here?
Why?
I'm thinking scientific.
For what?
What science?
Why would you need this as a science?
A hypothesis!
Scurpy!
I think...
I think you need to stop cooking.
I was just curious, like...
Is it the same like amount of fucked up genetics if it's like your third, like second cousin...
Compared to your like brother?
Oh yeah, because there's less similarities to the genetics.
Yeah, that's what I was saying!
The more...
The closer the genes are...
The more fucked up...
The byproducts are.
Because you can't have the genetics to be similar.
Because then there's like...
Like...
Issues.
Health issues.
So as long as...
Like...
So if it's like second cousin removed or something...
It's less fucked up than your fucking brother.
Or sister.
Okay, because I was just wondering...
If it's like...
Even if it was your second cousin, would it be as fucked up?
Like the kid?
It's still fucked...
Okay, the kid...
No, no, like the kid is what I'm talking about.
It's still fucked up.
No, morality...
Like morality-wise, it's fucked up no matter what.
Yeah, yeah.
But I'm wondering about the kid.
Well, the kid will be less fucked up than...
Than the other kids.
Okay, so they're not going to be the same amount of fucked up.
No, no.
Because it's all about genetic similarities.
It's about the genes.
But...
Okay, but yes.
Anyway, I think we've established how fucked up they will be genetically.
And morally.
So I guess we can...
How did we get on this topic again?
So we can move...
You were the one that asked me about this.
Oh no!
A way out!
It wasn't because of what I'm talking about.
Because of the way out and the brothers thing.
Anyway guys, I hope you guys had a...
This after game chat got a little bit cursed.
Just a little bit.
But I hope you guys had a great time.
Gumi, you should go play your TFT so you don't get knocked out.
I felt like I just learned a lot.
I'm not sure if I learned a lot.
I...
Because I actually watched a Tiki Talk recently about that one family in America.
What?
The one family in America.
The inbred family.
What?
The...
Lanny...
You don't know about the family?
What?
There was a documentary on them.
The Woodtakers of Odd West Virginia.
Huh?
Okay Gumi, stop cooking.
Gumi, stop cooking.
I think we gotta move on from the inbreeding.
I think we have to move on.
Anyways, that's why I was so interested in the science behind it.
Because I watched a documentary about it recently.
Okay.
Well, by documentary, I meant I watched a Tiki Talk about it.
Everybody just watches the Tiki Talks of movies and videos now.
We do that.
No, I watched a Tiki Talk about another person who made a video on them.
I was like, oh, so this person...
Anyways.
Anyways, GG, Gumi.
I can't believe we finished it.
We finally did it.
It took us a while, but we fucking did it.
GG, Gumi.
Don't...
Don't get knocked out in TFT.
We're gonna say...
Okay, see you two weeks from now.
Bye, Gumi.
Bye.
Love you.
Alright, that was like the most cursed topic that we've had for a while.
So...
But we did it, guys!
We beat It Takes Two, finally.
The stream...
One of the most streamed games for co-op.
Ever.
And we fucking finally did it.
I hope you guys had a great time watching us.
I'm gonna call it here.
Had to go to therapy in like three hours.
We just finished relation...
We just finished marriage counseling.
And now I have to go to actual therapy.
Later.
So, I'm gonna go head out now.
I hope you guys had a great time, everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for us, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.